president zielenski dear vladimir
dear citizens of ukraine
you are fighting to uphold your
sovereignty
and to protect your freedom in the face
of naked aggression
you have mobilized at every level to
defend and provide for your country
we can never match the sacrifices you
are making every day
but we can
and we will stand by your side
the european union has been with you in
this fight from the very beginning
providing economic military and
humanitarian support
we're supporting your brave soldiers on
the front line
your civil servants and civil society on
the home front
we are welcoming your families who have
sought shelter in the european union
our schools have opened their doors to
over three million ukrainian children so
they can continue to learn and study and
come home
once this war is over
together with you we will rebuild your
cities brick by brick
and replant your gardens and fields seed
by seed
thanks to your sacrifice
your children will grow up in a ukraine
that is just and free
there's a lot to do but we can do it
together
europe is with you today and in the long
run
slava ukrainian